I'm ready to fill
hello Greg Alva over here and I am John
John is here with me today we're gonna
watch the trailer for a magical movie
Doctor Strange Doctor Strange I'm gonna
let you guys know upfront
I love the Marvel movies I really do
am i one who's like read the comics no I
did grow up reading more of like Batman
and Nightwing so I'm not the most comic
knowledgeable guy you read novels I'm
really into the films i watch them all
multiple times okay
that's the credit use nothing Steven
strange
might I offer you some advice forget
everything that you think you're not the
teacher rose
your mind looking at the world through a
keyhole
you've spent your life trying to widen
it
you'll want to save the nice class
what if I told you that reality is one
of many
I don't believe in fairytales about
chakras or energy or the power of belief
you wonder what I see in your future
possibility
whoa
are you doing this
ways to save lives
ah so much you don't know
Superman kidding
that's another comic book thing so much
love I feel in that trailer like I feel
like they're really I don't know I don't
know anything about Doctor Strange you
know very little about just I know he
deals with magic that's as far as my
knowledge really goes and from my
understanding everyone loves that
Benedict Cumberbatch has been cast
there's something about him I'm just
always mesmerized when I'm I'm like
pulled into the scene the second he's on
screen you know there's something very
specific about what he looks like and
how he speaks and what his sort of
presence he's not just like a charming
British actor like he's got a
Cumberbatch Ernest yeah yeah there's a
slew has eyes just striking just really
women don't let go never and his voice
too I mean that sounds that seems like
it would lose him right well yeah that
that happens a lot when like British
actors do an American accent except for
like Daniel Radcliffe British actors
always sound a lot dweeby er when you
first hear this yeah with an American
accent it didn't occur to me but yeah I
guess he's American Pope Benedict
Cumberbatch shot with an American accent
you know I'm sure he's done it before
and something I haven't seen yeah um but
that is an intimidating American accent
he's got it down no he's got it down I
wouldn't expect him never for American
accent I'm very surprised a striking
voice he's like sexy he's like sexy you
know yeah well in a weird way yeah like
something very attractive but I don't
know if he's sex I'm traditionally sexy
man until the Swinton who I know is me
Cass is the ancient one who's history I
know nothing about yeah I remember there
was some controversy because I think
that was an Asian character in the comic
books ah
I think it went from like Asian man to
white woman which you know there was
vague controversy about but I loved
Tilda Swinton generally speaking and
especially that image of her like with
che
Ted and everything like you know she's
already got sort of an otherworldly
quality about hers and she's the kind of
actress that really falls into these
characters you know yeah like that's
what's cool about Benedict Cumberbatch
as well you got she would sell edge
before they say his name Chiwetel
Ejiofor you know it's close you got
these actors in here who are like great
freaking actors you know like these
actors are awesome they they are known
to get lost in their roles to see them
in this like matrix light magical world
and it looks really cool you know every
once in a while you get a film where
you're like this looks like it's trying
to be the matrix this looks like it's
trying to be the matrix and the closest
thing I could think of that finally
broke the mold was Inception where
you're like you could say that in some
ways but they've now taken sci-fi to
another level as well well and watching
this trailer I picked up notes the dojo
set reminded me the matrix the city
folded like the weird kaleidoscope City
reminded me of Inception or things that
reminded me a Batman Begins yeah and I
like that not just because of like some
type of nostalgia thing it feels like
it's doing something unique with it it
feels like it's doing it in the right
way that's what I want to see cuz I like
the guys who made this film a lot that
the the writer/director team and I'm I
just want to see how they use those
elements and make them their own
cuz especially like with the mandala
like kaleidoscope stuff in the building
when all the parts are kind of warping
around like that looks super cool and
unique yeah so I'm really excited to see
the visual magic of this man and I'm
sure the movies gonna be a lot more fun
marvel teaser trailers tend to be really
serious
sure healers you know yeah like the
ant-man one teaser was the lot was more
serious than people were expecting you
know the Iron Man three one and remember
being like really serious and epic the
Doctor Strange I'm sure will have a you
know surf flair to it deals of magic you
know I know
that'd be cool if it kept it on the dark
side but also managed to find that
awesome Marvel comedy that they get I
think they will I mean I'm always
curious about how like what kind of
personality you know the filmmakers are
allowed and bring versus what Marvel
wants to do and it never seems like
they're at least completely against
having their comedy like a lot of their
more recent stuff has been sans Ant Man
II a pretty serious
that's an interesting director they got
for it yeah a guy who did like Last
Exorcism
Emily Rose and not actually huh DX no
The Last Exorcism of Emily Rose that's
how the title goes not at oh yes Eli
Roth the Last Exorcism Emily Rose okay
left for a film where the two universes
came together yeah that's what happened
it's a real situation it's sinister so
the guy has done some films that are
pretty darn good you know
yeah one and this will also be
interesting this could be his Redemption
with the big Hollywood studio system cuz
a lot of what led to sinister was the
fact that he did The Day the Earth Stood
Still and that was a debacle and like he
tried to leave that set or something
like that because like it was apparently
not a very good filmmaking experience so
I'm curious as to how he'll handle that
kind of scope again I like it when him
and see Robert Cargill
work together and Cargill seems to know
he seems to have a good you know finger
on the pulse of you know comics and nerd
stuff yeah totally lows in a cool
background spill calm this seems like
it's extremely expanding the Marvel
world in a new direction yeah you know
like with guardians of the galaxy I know
like they they're they're definitely
bringing in star-lord for infinity war
and you know that takes place a whole
other universe and then you got Doctor
Strange which deals this whole other
kind of magical world you know which
could bring that more out of Thor in
some ways yeah like you said there's
elements inspired from like Batman
Begins said he like yeah like it does
feel kind of that Ra's al Ghul and
Batman story a little bit
I hope the ancient one doesn't turn out
to be an ancient [ __ ] that's for sure
she'll probably smack him around a
little bit you know be distant so that
he has to always yearn for her approval
I like these guys a lot I think they're
a cool choice because I know they're at
least some sort of macabre and more
horror elements that's part of the fun
of Marvel movies is to see what other
genres they collide stuff into so I
think scott derrickson and n see Robert
Cargill are a good combination for this
kind of thing this is the stuff I find
the most exciting with Marvel is like
this is a character I don't know a whole
lot about and it seems like a different
corner at least of the Marvel comic book
universe and Marvel cinema universe and
these are the ones that excite me the
most because
or you know dip to I don't know what
you're talking about I totally think
Zack Snyder should take over all just a
little bit of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe you doing your thing you guys
rock it's cool to see Marvel still like
you know trying to amp up their game and
might try to top themselves you know by
the time we get to infinity war this
will be the most chaotic thing ever that
it's gonna be a two-part for our trailer
just leave on time feature-length
trailer catching you up all this [ __ ]
like showing you all the other 50 of the
characters are going to be halfway
through they're gonna have to take up an
entire Convention Center just to get
them all in one shot and then just
imagine like I'm sure there will be even
more characters they're gonna tease and
hint
oh my god that is is gonna be like that
pose with that poster that you have or
is just like all the Marvel characters
like on a horizon honestly it's really
exciting to see them going down the
magical path because it's the magic
world is so different like if they if
this doesn't become like a typical
action-adventure flick and it becomes
something that does give us a different
world of magic I love it when science
tries to take on magic and they don't
win mmm you know like I like that kind
of fighting you know how is like what's
my Scarlet Witch is gonna be a powerful
one that's right what's her name
Elizabeth Olsen she's one of the old
she's like kinda relate to the Olsens
yeah I forget what the actual thing is I
don't know but she's one talented
actress she's yeah what solid actress I
would like her to have one of my babies
one of they just for the talent I just
wanna whatever really might be talented
son or daughter that I can push into
acting on my behalf I was making a joke
about taking one of the babies and
what'd you do you made your own joke no
listen sorry it's like whoa you know you
think you're doing improv next thing you
know you're standing next to a stand-up
comic hahaha that's good
there it's just saying to me like when I
think of like what's the most powerful
thing magic you can't beat that with
science I've seen movies like drag me to
hell I know what I'm talking about well
in that and that makes the magic is more
limitless I just gotta say them sorry I
had to interject I'm so sorry for her up
to you that's so sorry better okay I
don't care that I had to interject don't
cat it makes it like even more limitless
you know it could be a way of how we get
star wars like gets you think you know
it's all gonna like come together you
know yeah yeah yeah and you know how
they sex me well thanks man I'm
interested to see how they're gonna
weave the fabric of these worlds
together cuz some of them look like they
fit like some seem to fit in with the
others better than some of the other
ones well especially because we were
watching Jessica Jones and stuff like
that things like that have gotten more
excited too because we've seen the same
you know like four or five Marvel
characters for so long it's like okay
guy with superhero powers and we kind of
know what that means we're gonna get a
lot of martial arts and a lot of like
you know lasers and so like to see some
folks with different powers that aren't
necessarily that you know coming around
and great designer I don't know what all
of dr. Strange's powers are I'm sure
there will be some fighting and some
lasers but you know he strikes me as
being different than you know your
standard-issue superhero so I want to
see a sorcerer a story with some McCobb
stuff you know I think that would be
really fun that you said everything that
we have to say that's it for this little
trailer review hey folks if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe today
and become a reject John if you like his
personality there's a playlist of all
the videos season and if you like his
voice here's the dank ass stuffs podcast
he hosts I follow us on our social
networks I'm gonna Hulk out in my
bedroom for a second you know I get
really angry insert threats to plan you
know 15 minutes of hooking out I think
should do it really gave me mellow for
the rest of the week and then I spend
the day relaxing by restoring the
bedroom yeah it's my process yeah listen
to some personal develop - Buffy you're
sort of that